Okay, so what does a graph look like?
Wait.
No.
I've been conditioned to think of
a graph as a chart that shows trends,
like a line graph, or
a graph of a function.
But that's not what we're
talking about here.
Let me try again.
Our definition of a graph
looks more like this.
The purpose of a graph is to show
how different things are connected
to one another.
It's also sometimes called a network.
A graph is similar to
a tree in many ways.
For starters, these are called nodes or
vertices, and
these lines over here are called edges.
In fact, a tree is just a more
specific type of graph.
It's just like a binary
tree is a type of tree, and
a BST is a type of binary tree.
Here's an example of a valid graph,
where you can really start anywhere and
you'll follow some
path back to the start.
Since cycles like this one are possible,
graphs don't really have
a root node like trees do.
Graphs are really vaguely defined,
but we should keep it that way.
As you've probably come to expect,
we need to keep it vague so
our definition will encompass all of
the different use cases for our graph.
For example, I would love to
say that nodes are the parts of
graphs that store data, and edges
are just the connections between them.
But, edges can actually store data too.
Since graphs can seem really
abstract at the start,
let's make them more
concrete with some examples.
Let's imagine this graph
as a social network.
This node can be me.
I can draw the rest of
the graph like this.
Here, it's clear that nodes are people,
but
the edges between the nodes could be
describing any connection between us.
Maybe it's people who've met each other.
Here, two notes that
are connected by an edge,
sometimes called adjacent,
have met each other in person.
This could be a graph of people who've
lived in the same city at the same time,
or people who've worked
on a project together.
The nodes could contain
any amount of data,
like each person's full name, where
they live now, their birthday, etc.
As I said before,
edges could contain data, too.
Edges often contain data about
the strength of a connection.
For example,
these edges could show how many times in
the past week we talked to each other.
Okay, let's think about a new example.
Let's say this graph is my
travel plans for a big trip.
I'm going to fly from San Francisco
to Tokyo, then Kuala Lumpur,
then Delhi, then back to KL,
Tokyo, and SF.
The edges could contain no information,
or
they could contain how
long the flights are.
The information I decide to store will
depend on what I'm using this graph for.